welcome my name is Ori Kashi and I'm a
product manager on the cloud sequel team
in this video I'll show you how to
create run and manage sequel instances
using Google Cloud sequel cloud sequel
helps manage Monday and administrative
tasks for my sequel Postgres and
Microsoft sequel server databases so you
can focus on what matters let's walk
through how to create a sequel server
database on cloud sequel and connect to
it from sequel server management studio
you can set up an instance in just a few
steps let's go through the basics and
I'll point out some options for
additional configuration along the way
we'll start by navigating to cloud
sequel in the GCP console and clicking
create instance
this instance will be created in the US
and we'll leave the zone set to any so
cloud sequel can choose for us now let's
take a look at our configuration options
you can specify your Edition the
instance size high availability and more
for this demo I'll stick with standard
edition and I'll choose a four core high
memory instance maximizing memory is a
good choice for sequel server because it
can take advantage of the extra memory
for performance that said don't worry
too much about initial sizing you can
scale the instance up or down later
let's increase the storage capacity to
200 gigabytes because increasing disk
capacity also increases performance
check out the performance calculator on
the right as I add capacity my disk
performance increases which allows my
database to process more operations per
second I'll leave automatic storage
increases enabled so that I don't
accidentally run out of disk space
lastly let's ensure that the database
will automatically provide isolation
from failures we can do that by enabling
the high availability configuration
which for sequel server adds a standby
instance in a different zone now that
we're happy with the configuration of
our instance let's kick off the creation
it may take a few minutes for your
instance to create this is a great time
to grab a quick cup of coffee you can
also check the status of your instance
by navigating to your instance list once
you see a green check mark your instance
is ready
looks like our instance has finished
creating let's open the details page to
continue there are many ways to connect
to this instance within gtp for example
we could use App Engine compute engine
or container engine but we could also
connect from just about anywhere by
authorizing IP addresses or using the
cloud sequel proxy for this demo I'll
connect using a familiar tool sequel
server management studio I'll be running
sequel server management studio from a
GCE VM and so I'm able to connect
securely and easily via private IP once
I remote desktop into my VM I'll start
SMS and then put in the private IP of my
cloud sequel instance
I'm using the default user sequel server
and then I enter our root password from
before and now we're connected so let's
go ahead and create an insert some data
to begin I'll create a database next
I'll insert some data
finally let's make sure the data is now
in our database and it is great so to
recap we just created a cloud sequel
instance with high performance and high
availability and connected to it with
sequel server management studio now that
you've seen how to get started give it a
try you can learn more about Google
Cloud sequel in our free trial program
cloud.google.com slash free thank you
for watching
[Music]